i had a friend uh piss in a bottle
and then i went to the off the doctor
and then i
squirted that piss into the cup and then
i passed the drug test so the only
real test that i nailed in high school
was my drug one and i cheated
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming queen
a girl who has spent every past episode
still talking about her high school
theater program elise morales
and with us today we have such a funny
stand-up
writer and one of the co-hosts of the
dollop podcast right here on the all
things comedy network
but before all of that he was a graduate
of the university school of milwaukee
it's gareth reynolds hey
hey all right so excited to have you
um university school of milwaukee sounds
very
fancy what flavor of high school is that
public private it was a it was
a pri it was a private school um
i went to it it went went from
kindergarten all the way to high school
so i hung in there for the whole time
and uh
gotten a lot of trouble and uh yeah
and did and yeah it was a lot a lot of
rich kids and then and then some of the
kids who were
uh a little more like me who were like
jesus christ our friends are rich
but that was great too because it's all
yeah you always have an indoor pool to
go to
was that well that that is a beautiful
thing
it was great was there like an a
religious affiliation to it at
all or was it just like fancy people of
all stripes are welcome here
it was not religious but it i always
think back on this because we had to
sing
before we ate lunch every day and i it
did not occur to me as crazy when we did
it but we used to sing
this is amazing god is great god is good
and we thank him for this food ah
man and i like as i get older i'm like
that is
[ __ ] bananas yeah that is it's not
even like
a prayer it's just like a real like it's
like with something like a principal
wrote it was like there we go
that's biblical yeah no this is this is
good
this is good and then they can eat the
hash browns and chicken nuggets because
of god
because he made them god god had a hand
in this
like the squad yeah he's in the back
with a hair net like i hope they like it
how do they like the macaroni good okay
really like
when i think back on the food that i ate
in school
i would say an abomination to god
oh yeah well i mean if he was into
nutrition at a bomb i mean
what you could eat at school was crazy
when i i mean
there was a there was a brief respite
when michelle obama was like hey these
kids shouldn't pizza shouldn't be a
vegetable
but yeah it was i i enjoyed it
but it was also garbage food i mean
when i got to school in the morning
which was first of all at like
6 45 a.m i think about that all the time
as well
just it's the that was the worst job i
ever had was going to school
horrible i would never i would never
accept a job on those terms
no no i where you work at home homework
i mean
it is complete indoctrination without
question anyway sorry keep going live at
6 45
you work for nine hours
test you regularly and then you get home
and there is more work
like lots more work absolutely not
except that
when i got to school in the morning i
would pound we had um
like vending machines and i would just
have a full sugar coke
every single day yeah i would do the
same i would just pound caffeine all i
would take um
what the hell would they like
amphetamine essentially i would be like
taking like
vibrant or whatever and um and that's
before i like i discovered my friends
had ritalin and stuff
but i would take like vi i mean i was
just like i tried like the diet of a
truck driver
because the hours were so ludicrous and
the work was so tedious
i mean do you remember like i think like
when people fly on planes and you see
the guy who's like
like head nodding himself i was i mean
my my goal like after lunch every day
was to be like how do you actually stay
up and awake i would always
i would wake up because i would get that
sensation
like i would start i would have a dream
that my desk was falling through
the sky and that yeah right where you
have those little dreams about like
i should pee and then you're like i
dreamt i pissed and you're like but i
didn't it's just like very
linear dream logic yes and
and then you get like i remember i would
get in trouble for falling asleep in
algebra and i'm like
babe it's 7 a.m and this is the most
boring [ __ ] i've heard in my life
i wish i had the balls to call my
teachers babe
i would love to be like lighting having
a cigarette like babe would just calm
down babe
i'm i'm asleep relax i'm a little tired
okay i overdid it on the vino last night
baby come on
i did have an antagonistic relationship
with my algebra teacher mr hubbach um
what are these names they don't they why
is it that name
teacher names i've like 55 percent of
them i've never heard in the real world
again
absolutely not what was his name
i mean it sounds like a euphemism for
genitalia it
does and he
well i had a very antagonistic
relationship with him and one time i had
to meet with him after school
and when i walked in to meet with him
he was eating two hot dogs at the same
time
like was he entered in the like hot was
it july 4th
was it nathan's privately eating was he
dunking them in like
water like they do in the competition
and just pounding them
they were fully dressed hot dogs and he
looked at me and i looked at him and
like
it was understood between us that the
meeting was not gonna happen
because i i just like went to my bus i
was like like i i don't have to listen
to you
yeah i was like listen man we're not
gonna go over the test
you're double-deckering hot dogs this is
not
i don't listen to you you listen to
nobody yeah exactly
who are who's giving you rules yeah who
who trained you
to train others no no mr hoobach
i had i had mr lang as my algebra
teacher
and he had cl like before i even really
knew what lsd was
i was like this man has definitely taken
a lot of it
and you could literally say mr lane will
you tell us about the time you went to
the pink floyd concert and he'd be like
we're not doing that again today
very quickly they had a giant pig and he
would like draw the p and he would like
do it he like
he loved the experience so much that he
would be like five minutes i'll tell you
about the concert
so since you were at a school that like
you
started from elementary school was there
like
lore about teachers once you got to the
high school like were you like oh my god
you don't want to have this person or
this person
if you ask him about pink floyd he's
he'll tell you
yeah you definitely had a sense of like
um i mean because it was all sort of
connected too so it was like
you would kind of uh know who the
teachers were i mean you wouldn't
necessarily know
too much but yeah you would definitely
be able to get a vibe and you were
familiar with who was in charge and
familiar with who to be afraid of
and then also just people that you would
see as like huge intimidating people
and then you'd finally be in their class
and you'd be like oh my god i'm in doc's
class you know
um but yeah definitely i don't know if
it was an advantage or not because you
would be
you know you would definitely be i was
just scared all the time but teachers
because i i
was not good with authority and not good
at school so
was that like did that follow you like
were you a troublemaker from
day one or did you like grow
into troublemaking over the course of
your time there
i was a troublemaker the whole time and
then i think i really
found my voice in high school like late
middle school high school i was like i
can be a huge distraction
like i definitely i i mean multiple
issues i mean the school was very uh
strict
i had to wear uh a tie and a sport coat
and so i just was like i would forget
things and i would have to go to the
lost and found and i'd end up wearing
like it looked like tom hanks at the end
of big
and um and so uh but yeah i definitely i
think eventually i just was like
i had so little interest in school that
i really did i was like i'm here to have
make laughs make jokes that's
that's my purpose did you were you like
known as a class clown at that time did
you
win class clown no i
i definitely was known as a class class
i mean it was actually a big
disadvantage because i would go into
classes now and teachers would no
no they would immediately be like oh
this kid's a [ __ ] like you know i
was on probation when i walked in
essentially
um and so they i and then i didn't win
best class clown when they gave those
awards i was very disappointed because
there's some really good ones there's
like most likely to be success you know
all these really nice ones and i won
uh most likely to leave campus during a
free period because i smoked cigarettes
so i won that and i was like that's not
good but i mean it was the word was out
that i was
a lot of my friends got expelled and so
my friends were all these kids who were
at a public school and so they would
come and pick me up and stuff so the
school eventually was definitely
frowning upon
me and my crew no it's kind of like you
won the bad boy award
in a way i guess i did but i wish they'd
put it like that
instead of just like most likely to
drive down a cigarette was just sort of
like
that's depressing yeah most likely to
smell kind of yeah stinky as kid yeah
most likely to have yellow fingers so
what was some of
like what was your biggest trouble
do you do you remember the the things
that really
got you got you in the hot seat uh there
was a lot um
[Music]
there was a time when i i mean i smoked
weed in high school and
i used to go to this uh this this guy
mike z's place to buy weed and um and he
he was he he had like he would always be
benching and playing video games like
right on dealer brand and um
a kid got in trouble for something
unrelated to it but he's
he turned myself and a couple other
friends in for being at this guy's place
and then so i ended up getting uh
randomly drug tested for the rest of
high school at one point
your high school had the authority to
they had the authority
they had the authority to say if you
want to be here you have to do this
they were not like i mean you know yeah
it's total [ __ ] i mean i knew it was
[ __ ] then and i didn't know anything
um did you like did you try to get past
the the drug test did you do anything i
cheated on a drug test once yep i
uh i had a i did not know we'd get here
i i had a friend uh piss in a bottle and
then what i did was i put it in an oxy
bottle like oxy like for pimples and
stuff
and i put an oxy bottle and then before
i was going to take it i was in the
shower
and um and i filled the sink up with
warm water hot water and i put that in
there
and then i went to the off the doctor
and then i
squirted that piss into the cup and then
i passed the drug test
wow pretty ballsy and then i also was
able to i took uh
goldenseal too which was a thing then
which was like would help you beat it
but
that was like my secondary point i
remember always hearing that you could
take
niacin to beat your drug
test which i i never
had to do but that was always i was like
that's really important information for
me to know
oh yeah i was deaf once i beat one i was
like all right
and they only gave me one that was all i
ended up having was one
um and i won so the only real test that
i nailed in high school was my drug one
and i cheated
hello everyone luxuriously coming
at you in my college improv sweatshirt
could i be cooler to tell you that
today's episode
of the roast of your teenage self
podcast is sponsored
by candid you know all the things that
we'd love to do for ourselves but
haven't done for whatever reason like
getting any other sweatshirt for me
i always wanted straighter teeth and a
better smile
you know i i never had braces in high
school
never had that experience never had that
day where you got the braces off and you
came to school and everyone was like oh
my god
she's a woman now but i'm done putting
it
off and thanks to candid straightening
my teeth is
simpler easier and more comfortable than
ever
candid clear aligners are comfortable
removable
and practically invisible unlike wire
braces
so you can transform your smile without
anyone
noticing plus your treatment is
prescribed and monitored remotely by a
licensed orthodontist who's an
expert in tooth movement and that's all
done
from the comfort of your own home candid
not only works with orthodontists
never general dentists like other
companies
plus your supervising orthodontist will
be with you every
step of the way so you can get that full
i'm 14 and my mom told me i gotta get my
teeth fixed
feeling without um having to look like
you're 14
and getting your teeth fixed again it's
a beautiful thing with candid your
treatment includes remote monitoring by
the same orthodontist who created your
plan
so you never have to wonder how you're
doing you'll always
know and i love that the average candid
treatment is just
six months and you'll start seeing
results way before then
and it costs thousands less
than braces because face it regular
braces
really expensive you're gonna need mom
and dad to be footing that bill
not now not with candid so start
straightening your teeth today right now
all of my listeners can save 75
on candid starter kit go to candidco
dot com slash teen self and use the code
teen self that's candid co
dot com slash teen self code
teen self take advantage of this limited
time offer to save
75 on your starter kit candid
co.com teen self code
teen self get that smile poppin people
you know you want it
let me cheat it and i cheated and i
cheated off someone else
it's also like so crazy to think about
like carrying piss around with you
man when you are that deep into this
i mean they i mean it's really it's how
society works in a way
it's like you build the fence we'll
figure out a way to get through it and
it was just a good example of that where
i was like
your rules are really [ __ ] so i will
fight your [ __ ] rules with more
[ __ ]
and see who wins and worst case scenario
i was going to go to the school where
all my friends were
so what was that like what was that like
having like
public school friends but then also
being at this
fancy private school it was weird it was
really weird because
um i mean i i definitely had friends
from my school
but they were also friends with kids
from the public school and um
i you know i mean my school did not like
me towards the end it's it's really
sucked honestly it like became very
difficult and
um and uh and my friends and the truth
is that i
my parents had such a shitty marriage i
was really going through a lot of [ __ ]
and so i definitely leaned on like
partying uh and i enjoyed it it wasn't
like i was like what's wrong i wasn't
like janice joplin i was like this is
great
um but uh but i definitely
was struggling and the school did not
really take an approach of like
um you know they they just looked at the
behavior and didn't really look at the
route and so it
it really made me want to rebel more but
i was definitely i had teachers who
really liked me and were like
you know he's a good kid he's a funny
guy but uh
he's lost and then i had teachers who
were just like i don't want to deal with
this
and um it just became a very frustrating
experience where i
i you know barely got through it
honestly well i feel like that's so
interesting because obviously like
on the dollop you guys talk about
history
and stuff so you have like
like you you can be could have been
interested in that subject
perhaps at the time if someone had found
the key
to your brain they don't they don't
teach they did not teach me
i it honestly shocks me all the time on
the podcast because we'll we'll talk
about a subject that i'm familiar with
or a person who i'm familiar with
like harry tubman yeah and and then
when i go i'm like harriet tubman at my
high school was
just a footnote there was a real there
was very little
to it and then the reality is that she
was like
the baddest person like she was such a
badass
and it's it it honestly it's very
bizarre because
i do think it is a calculated decision
and curriculum
to potentially not it's not maybe not
necessarily like a race thing
but it's like she didn't take [ __ ] she
fought the system and she
you know put a lot of dents in the
system and i think that they are like
you don't want to hear about these
radicals too much you know
um so i think i think they choose to not
teach you the stuff that is maybe not
necessarily important but like
uh you know revolutionaries and so i i
think that all the time yeah
yeah i think i mean i think that you're
definitely true there and it's so
interesting because especially with
history like
i'm i'm a history lover and i feel like
you have to go out of your way to make
it as boring as they make it
where they're yeah oh you should
actually learn the dates of all these
battles
instead of like what harriet tubman was
actually up to
or brown or any of that stuff it's like
that's really interesting and this
battle is the
like boring as [ __ ] totally if they had
taught john brown
i mean that is a like an amazing story
that they
just choose to not teach i think also
because you have to kind of
you have to kind of cover the tracks to
some extent of the racist history of the
country so
you know there's probably not a ton to
choose from and a lot of it is based on
[ __ ] you know like you spend time
learning about christopher columbus
it's like and then you're like you know
10 years later you're like wait what the
[ __ ] or thanksgiving
and you're like these stories are not
real these are not real stories that
they've taught
you were at this school for like
so so many years what was your
like did you um did you do
extracurriculars were you involved with
sports or were you just like i'm
partying i'm making trouble i'm
not in like [ __ ] all this noise i
actually
i had um i had i mean i i had a couple
things i
started doing improv i started doing
comedy sports in high school and then
that was great that kind of opened me up
to like
uh this world that was just totally
separate from school and was just about
being funny and having fun
and then i had a teacher uh named miss
woodard
who came to the school i think my
sophomore year and just was like
she was like you have some ability and
she like actually made me go like oh
[ __ ]
there is more out there i had no plans
to go to college
i didn't really know what the [ __ ] i
thought i would stay in milwaukee and
kind of try to do comedy sports
and she was like um you know let's let's
get you going somewhere and so
theater became a thing i did i still was
very
um yeah i still i could have focused
more on it because
but but she definitely like lifted me up
to a level where i actually had like
belief
in something and that was just something
i hadn't had
in my entire high school so by the time
i was a senior
you know i was on a path where i was
like okay i'm gonna i'm gonna go to
college i'm gonna pursue
some version of entertainment and um
yeah i mean it's
super lucky super lucky what got you to
comedy sports did you just like see them
and think like i'm gonna try out
they had a high school league they had
high school leagues and a friend of mine
i mean this is sort of to what we were
speaking about earlier where
an advantage to being in the same place
the whole time so my friends would have
older
brothers and sisters and one of my
friends older brother's friend
who they would just beat the [ __ ] out of
us when we were middle school but when i
became a freshman he approached me and
he was like hey i run comedy sports
you should join you know and i was like
oh great yes
yeah yeah i beat you sensely and you
came back for more
uh and then that sort of got that got me
into the high school world
and then that actually when i was 16 i
started working there
um so that i mean it was just yeah those
those
two things taught me that um i could
actually
go outside of the school to some extent
and
find things that gave me purpose you
know that i enjoyed doing that's so cool
because like
something we've talked about on the
podcast a lot is like
how long it takes to get to that
realization of like oh comedy is a thing
that i could do
and so by doing comedy sports and being
like oh okay well
this is the high school league but i see
that there's an adult league and this is
actually i'm working here now
it's like you got kind of at a young age
to see that a career in comedy is a real
thing that can happen very true yeah
i i especially i mean i you know i was
from i was from brown deer which is a
very small
i mean it just the concept of being able
to do
things i saw on television did not have
i just there was there was no connection
i mean i you know i watched so many old
sitcoms i was like raised by sitcoms and
television but it never
occurred to me that all that useless
time watching it and sort of locking in
how story goes
you know subliminally would come in
handy later in my life when i was like
oh i'm very familiar with the structure
of how television works
exactly it's like oh actually i have an
encyclopedic knowledge of some of the
best
television pilots i was like i know
everything that james burrows does
and i'm like it's it is very weird but
um
but yeah it it it's certainly like
it was it was just a very lucky break
honestly to be able to sort of
like see these few pathways out of there
and actually lock into one and get out
because otherwise
i remember i was at comedy sports i
think i was 18 maybe or 17
and i was talking to one of the guys who
worked there who i thought was like the
best and he was i mean he's
just comedically hilarious and um and he
was like get out of here he's like don't
say
he was like seriously he's like i i wish
i had left leave
and i was like oh [ __ ] cool thank you
so okay you're doing improv like outside
of school with this group your
your trouble making which i feel like
takes a there's a certain confidence in
yourself that it takes to be
a true troublemaker yeah your your
partying all that stuff
is this like sort of confidence that
you're bringing on stage that you're
bringing in the classroom translating to
other parts of your life like how
how how was uh teen gareth with the
ladies
i i it's funny i actually was um
this happened in college too where that
well in high school pretty good honestly
like they were they were certainly like
i mean for like yeah i mean i i think i
did have like kind of blind confidence
and um
so they were definitely you know i
definitely dated
some girls in high school but when i got
to college i really was so clueless like
i remember the end of my freshman year
like a girl was like there's a lot of
girls who have crushes on you and i was
like really
i don't like i just never actually
really connected those
dots but but i did pretty well in high
school for
you know for a [ __ ] who was didn't
know what the hell he was doing
you know bad boy award so well what i
started doing was i started to wear
uh my last year or two
i went because i think they changed like
some uniform rules or something so i got
platform shoes so i wore these huge
platform shoes and i wore bell-bottom
khakis and um just took uh
i mean i think there's some in the
pictures where you can see that i am
a lunatic some photos because you
actually have some great looks well
this photo this first one is this the
school uniform
this was this is actually the pla i'm
wearing the platforms and
yeah we gotta talk about the shoes
well okay so this is my lap this is me
graduating from high school
and so there's mr uh cornwell
with the blue cape on apparently he was
a super uh
teacher and and he he was the dean
and he he was very stern with me but
also understood that i was a [ __ ]
and so he kind of had like he was kind
of cool towards the end
and then i decided what i was gonna do
was i was gonna tuck a monkey tail
up in my jacket and then when i finally
got up there to get my diploma i was
gonna let the monkey tail drop so if you
look there you see a little
monkey tail popping out of the back so
everyone's laughing and i'm shaking
hands with the like headmaster guy
and he's like not sure why everyone's
laughing and i'm like it's a pleasure
it's an honor thank you so much um
and i remember asking the dean that day
i said can i get in trouble if i do
something here and he goes look this is
your last day you can do whatever the
[ __ ]
and i was like okay great i do love that
the shoes weren't enough you were like i
also need to be wearing
a monkey well they were to me at that
point i was like these are shoes these
are not funny shoes these are just my
these are my shoes these are my heels
they look like like a little boot
and i mean they're they're i would say
that they're stylish now like i would
wear those shoes but it is interesting
to see them on a teenage boy
in his school uniform i like i said i
don't i
who know i mean i would go to the i've
bought 95
of my clothes from the goodwill and i
really don't know where a lot of these
i look back and i really don't know what
the hell it's not i feel like it was a
different person like i don't know
what the hell is going on in this
person's mind even though it is me
but this person was just like yeah he
was just like i'm gonna rock platform
shoes and then i had this monkey tail
um i don't know what i was going for but
something happened so i took it you know
perfect let's see
next photo here okay so this looks like
it's you and the crew
what's your choice here this is probably
freshman year
um and these or maybe sophomore year so
this is one like i mean
i mean look at me i just look so okay
i found great solace in kurt cobain like
nirvana became
and then he killed himself yeah right
yeah
yes and then uh and then he killed
himself and i was like
my only friend is gone um but i'm in a
nirvana nevermind t-shirt i think we're
probably drinking sprecker beer here
i don't know where we are but this is my
this is
on the left there on our left is my
friend brian harrison who
it's a lunatic a lunatic the first time
i went to his house
we were probably freshmen and he goes
hey man we could he was uh he was
ecuadorian
and his whole family's ecuadorian he was
like it's cool we can smoke cigarettes
in my room i was like okay
and then his mom was knocking she's
going brian brian
and i was like she goes it smells like
smoke and i was like can we smoke and he
goes yeah it's cool [ __ ] her
and then she came in and we were smoking
and we couldn't smoke in there
and so we were in tremendous trouble and
i was like vargas his middle name is
vargas then there's my
a buddy of mine who i still keep in
great touch with named brett stepkey
uh who's bald now and then my buddy
graham over there and yeah this is just
us
i mean this is kind of what it was it
was just a lot of sitting around
in people's basements or when people's
parents were gone just drinking beer and
rum or whatever we could get our hands
on and just
those yeah like running around a
finished basement
wreaking havoc on like a very nice
suburban home
oh yeah well my also i eventually turned
my basement into a crazy little party
den
like my brother was 12 years older so he
really greased the wheels for me
um he like had gotten a dui like he just
like
there was like trouble there so i was
able to kind of just be like hey
it's not abnormal to smoke pot in your
basement don't freak out mom
you know um would your brother get you
beer where were you getting your alcohol
from
we actually would get our alcohol from
multiple places but before any of us had
fake ids there was a mentally challenged
guy who a buddy of mine worked with at a
gas station
named lance who just didn't give a [ __ ]
and
he would get the orders were i'm not
even trying to be rude or any like he
the orders would not be correct
but we would be like this is fine like
we'll smoke menthols and we'll drink
this
shitty beer what you know yeah um well
at that point like
when you're going to lance with your
order you are making a deal with the
devil a little bit like you can't be
like
i'm sir i know yeah you can't be
15 and be like um i wanted a light beer
you know you're just like i will drink
it i'll drink it from a hat i'll drink
it out of a boot i don't give a [ __ ]
absolutely this is something we talk
about on the podcast a lot too but just
like
the insane alcohol that you would drink
at that time like oh yeah like
making like ever clear drinks it's like
you know you don't
have you can also get drunk and not do
this
yeah i mean i would never literally
would not know what campari is
except for the fact that like i stole a
bottle of it once and i had alcohol in
it
and i i just and vermouth too right
vermouth just like down he used to drink
vermouth and diet mountain dew
like reg and it it it tasted as
horrendous as it sounds but we were like
as a play
absolutely burned a hole in your stomach
the moment oh yeah
oh without quite there there will be a
doctor someday will be like well it's
inoperable
this looks like it was this vermouth and
diet coke you've got a bit what we call
a vermouth hole
it's right in your tummy i'm a doctor
who says
yeah it's this is not a doctor
no it's lance lance it's trump's doctor
um yeah it's that first one who looked
like uh
a val kilmer character the guy the first
guy who's like i don't know
he's the healthiest man alive i don't
know he wrote the note i don't know
eventually that guy just gave up he's
like i don't know
i don't want to be interviewed
um all right let's go through some of
the other photos because you sent in
some really good ones
okay um okay this is okay
this year with a young lady
is this a costume or is this what you
wore to homecoming
it's a great question um that's a great
question
uh this was i believe
this was the other school's prom
and this is my girlfriend at the time
beth
and uh this was not a bit
i like to me this again like i'm saying
it feel
i feel very separate i would love to sit
down and talk to this person
because i don't understand it either
somehow this happened i don't really
know how it looks like i invented
steampunk
um white gloves that's a cane clearly
uh sunglasses
shades inside a top hat
just not not okay
have you ever seen that vi it was like
it's like a viral photo that comes up
every halloween
of a woman who showed up dressed as the
babadook
to like a movie watching night and no
one else is dressed up
no this looks exactly
like i feel her vibe
i feel her vibe so strongly you you look
like you can't showed up
dressed as the babadook i i mean but
look at beth like beth
is not like hey let's be crazy together
that's like oh we're addressed to prom
and i was like i'll i'll look like i
have a train that goes through time
[Laughter]
you look like beth beth got this photo
back and was like i was in this photo
alone
i don't know yeah or yeah i
i i mean like this is where i learned
that i'm a ghost
like in my life where someone's like you
were never there i'm like oh my god that
makes sense
i'm a ghost you're like beth went to
prom alone
you are dressed kind of like a dandy
like there's like an oscar wilde
yeah the look doesn't the actual facial
expression itself does not
help get away from that either this it's
the the
the grimace of a dandy
so was this a long-term
girlfriend of yours uh this was not
that long term it i mean it was probably
a few months she went to the other
school like i said
um but yeah she was definitely like
maybe like yeah like certainly one of
the first girls where i was
hanging out with for like a good amount
of time i think we're probably juniors
there
okay um yeah and i think we're probably
on
for about four months or so but like
yeah she she was great she was awesome
so given that like you were at this
school for such a long time
did you mostly date people who you met
outside of school
or because it feels like you would have
known people for such a
long period of time that maybe the
the pool of like cool new girls to me
was well but you know it
because of the adolescent transformation
it became like a fresh pool
uh in high school you know it was sort
of like oh my god you're not just
the girl i threw clay at you're
attractive you know um
so to some extent but then i also think
it it was sort of helpful in a way
because it was like if you'd known
someone for so long
and then they came out on the other side
of adolescence you know and you were
attracted
to them it was a little bit easier to be
like you already knew them it wasn't
like
going to high school and being like oh
there's all these new girls i don't know
it was sort of like
we all got older together at the same
time and they kind of came out the other
side like
hey i'm weird now or like i'm a fat kid
you know whatever it was
um but uh but then also yeah definitely
like
i enjoyed going to the other parties and
like meeting girls i'd never met before
you know what were like um i mean you
said you were
into nirvana what were also your like
other cultural
touchstones at the time
um i really there was
uh david cross and bob odenkirk had a
sketch show called mr show
and uh and that was like
i would only get video tapes from
friends of mr show recorded off of hbo
but i remember when i'd get a new season
um
that my my really good friends and i
would like my friend brett
we would watch we would just we would
burn holes through these tapes
watching mr show like it was it was just
unlike anything i'd ever seen before and
actually
completely um
changed what i wanted to do and like
when i got to
college you know got into a sketch group
and then i was like holy [ __ ] i'm gonna
be writing
you know sketches and and everything i
had was like
mr show-esque was like either like
adjacent to mr show or something like
that but that
that was a huge huge uh influence on me
that
that that in conjunction with comedy
sports and theater
you know again like when you are so
i mean i really did not do well in
school um when you're like that you feel
[ __ ] useless because that's really
the only
bar to measure yourself by his grades
and so when you don't stop
it's yeah yeah it's the boss's approval
and so
when you're not good at it you feel like
[ __ ] and so when i actually was
going oh there's there are these things
that not only do i like but i get
validated from
people about doing you know i mean that
was just like
it was just a matter of putting a sale
in that gale force you know
yeah theater was definitely like that
for me because i was like just kind of
like a middling student but i
knew that i was good in place yeah
that feeling uh you were talking about
with mr show i got the same thing when
my friend lent me
the first season of the office which i
think came out
like my senior junior year
and i remember watching it and just
being like i've never seen anything
funnier than this
like unbelievable yeah it's
it's interesting too because even when i
go back and i'll watch some old mr show
it's it's not
as it's not as great i mean some of it
is amazing but it's not as great but the
influence it had on me was it just kind
of opened my eyes to like
you can there is no limit to what comedy
can be really i mean you can do anything
in a theater
well sometimes also watching shows that
are so influential like that
you'll watch a joke and you're like oh
that joke's done to death but then you
have to remember
no this was the first time it was done i
watched planes trains and automobiles
recently and it was and i was like this
movie is not as good as i remember and
that's exactly why because
they've made that movie 20 times since
then
and sometimes just as good or better
even but that at the time
was a pocket in time where it was like
this is this is the best of this
ever yeah it's like oh actually you're
watching it be
invented when you're watching this show
yeah
let's go through the rest of your photos
um let's see where okay
who do we have here so that's my brother
like i was saying he was going to grease
the wheels for me he's 12 years older
um this is when i dyed my hair and
eyebrows black for no reason
and um and this i showed him
every act very funny because every
sunday my mother lives in england
and my brother uh and i we see each
other but we but so we do a uh
family photo time my brother my mother
and i and we go through old pictures
and when i found this one we were like
this really summarizes
this is the epitome of our relationship
when i was in
i was a [ __ ] lunatic i was out of
control and my brother would my brother
was awesome and very cool but a lot more
docile
and so this is me like making him wear
me as a backpack and he's just like
jesus [ __ ] christ
just get off of him his face truly looks
like he's like well
this is my teenage brother yeah he's
like i expected more from being batman
than just having this [ __ ]
on my back but but he was cool i mean he
would like hang out with us but i would
one of the things i would do is i would
always sing songs to him and he would
just punch me
like it was just it was pretty spacey
so okay you just dyed your hair and
eyebrows black because you were like
it's time for
change because you want to be shocking
i'd had my hair
bleached blonde and then yeah and then i
think i just
i don't even i think actually i believe
it was supposed to be like a temporary
thing
and then it was permanent and then i was
like oh whatever i think someone was
like
this is a temporary die and uh and it
wasn't
or no someone goes it'll wash out with
prell that's what it was
and so i bought this prell and i was
like when the [ __ ] does this [ __ ] come
out and it just never came out so i have
black hair for like
and it's like actually if you put black
hair dye on fair hair
it's not gonna come out it's black it's
black
and yeah so this is a an interesting
phase but how long did
how long did it last forever i mean it
it had to fully fully
grow out complete you know months months
and months months
less than black hair i was always dyeing
my hair like crazy colors and stuff in
high school and doing a
terrible job and like i would like get
it on my
ears because would oh yeah like the
bottom and i would get it on my ears and
then i would just have like a purple
ear i looked i would also pierce
my ears like without i had
two there was two times where i just had
someone pierce my ear both were terrible
one time
was my cousin pierced it and he numbed
it by putting a fish stick on it
and uh and then he put a stud in it and
my ear turned purple but not from hair
dye from infection
and then another time the girl i was
dating uh she tried to do it and the
needle broke off halfway through
and so it was just the extraction was
[ __ ] brutal oh my god i would do it
right in the cartilage up there
oh my god doing the cartilage oh
oh my god okay let's go to this next
photo okay
so this is this is a great example of
again me being like who was i um
so this is i i had this idea i wanted to
go to sears to have uh family pictures
taken
and my father was not my father was not
part of our family at the time and so
it was my mother my brother and my
brother's girlfriend at the time
and i tried to sell them on going to
sears to take family portrait like jokey
family portraits
but i was astounded at
the no that i like the resounding no way
and then so i called my buddy oren who
remains one of my best friends and who
was at the same school as i
and um and i said get on your sunday's
best
we're going to sears and so we went to
sears we got really high
and we went to sears and we just rented
you know a little session in the sears
photography and this was one of the
pictures the guy had
they had all these dumb pro i mean it
was totally like the guy was like what
the [ __ ] is going on
um is that a giant o
yeah because his name was orang he held
an o we were very creative
very creative
yeah sort of a cutesy little like hello
kind of move he was a bigger gentleman
still is
but uh and that hair is gone but um
but yeah we so we just had this weird
photo session at sears and
and i have a i mean there's more of them
i yeah there's
i mean we had all these ones printed up
they were just it was really weird
um was that expensive i it must not have
been because otherwise it would not have
happened
uh yeah it must not have been i mean i
was working at the time i was working at
comedy sports on the weekend so maybe i
had some cash but
but yeah i wouldn't have paid a lot i
mean so i don't know but it could have
been a lot
i know i always want to do those
old-time photos on the boardwalk but
lost prohibitive those things oh yeah
well yeah
i mean this was like this was like at
northridge in milwaukee like
this was and this is [ __ ] you know 97
or 98 so it's like
things things were a little cheaper back
in my days it's
that's also such a fun level of mischief
where like you kind of feel like you're
doing something bad but in reality like
you're just paying money to sears and
some old
like whatever man yeah and like thinking
like this guy's this guy's gonna think
this is [ __ ] great and the person is
just like
just get out of here as soon as possible
you know like just completely over it
not finding any humor in it my life is
hell
yeah i'm being i my two bosses right now
are two stu
stoned high school kids so things aren't
great over here
yeah exactly like the last thing i want
to do is deal with your antics
but yeah we're holding an oh because his
name's oren he's like awesome we have
about two more left
so hurry so by the end of
high school once you had graduated did
you really
like did you have a plan to do comedy at
that point
what was your vision leaving high school
of what you were going to do
well i knew i was going to uh i knew i
was going to emerson college in boston
and um and i didn't really know i mean i
think my
i think what i thought it was going to
be was like a serious actor um
i think i really thought that that was
going to be it because i got into this
this theater program there
um but then really what it became was it
became just
a place to meet funny like-minded people
like my writing partner
i met my third day of college you know
and like we've worked together since so
it just kind of was a breeding ground to
meet a bunch of people who were also
kind of like me who weren't really sure
what they were going to do but knew they
wanted to be
be funny but i i i don't know i don't
know what i thought in my head i mean i
i probably
i probably again i mean i would i was
like i part of me thought i'd go to la
right away
instead of college and then when i was
actually going to college i think i just
thought
you know this will just be a quick quick
session into my
fast fame and fortune when i moved to
los angeles at 24.
100 on all those things so did you like
when you're because you were saying you
know you weren't a good
student so when it came time to like
apply to colleges and you were like [ __ ]
i gotta get into a theater program
was there like did you have to like
hustle some stuff i mean i imagine for
that it was more like an
audition type situation but it was
it was my grades were [ __ ] i mean i
couldn't i i was
accepted into a couple theater programs
that i couldn't go to the college
because of uh
because of grades so um you know it was
shitty because i
was like i really wanted to go to bu and
i got into the bu theater program but
the guy there and then um and then i was
you know they wouldn't take because of
my grades emerson
i mean emerson is like kindergarten
college and they were like you seem too
stupid for this
um so uh but uh
yeah i mean it was it was mainly
auditioning and it was mainly i had to
write a
i had to write you know a little story
and i wrote it about at
comedy sports ended up being a ballet
parker where i would wear a tutu
and i would pirouette people around a
parking lot and like direct them to
spaces
and so um and so i wrote a story about
that and
people seem to like that and then it was
just auditioning with monologues
and again the the teacher miss woodard
really helped me get it together
um the funniest story is that when i was
auditioning for north carolina school of
the arts
they were like and what's your song and
i was like oh i don't have a song and
they were like oh you need a song and so
i got
faxed over um some hello dolly lyrics
and i remember my brother and i were in
a hotel my brother came with me we had
to go to chicago for it my brother came
with me and we had a hotel and i
remember
at the first line he's just like well
just practice it with me and i just go
okay go
put on your sunday's best there's lots
of world out there
and we both lost our [ __ ] laughing we
were like this is not good
and then i went and did it and they i
mean i swear they were sitting there
like this is
a [ __ ] disaster and i just you know
that that feeling that i beca
i've now become so familiar with where
you're bombing
and you have to continue um in sync
but also not even just bombing your
singing
and your body sing bombing is
it's a different it's a different bomb
the same the sing bomb
i i have one from when i was auditioning
to into the on
for into the woods at my high school
that still
haunts me a singer that's tough horrible
i was like you know what i started off
in the wrong place and i am not gonna
get this back that's actually very well
put because i think it it really is
you've got to hit that for you know and
i'm sure i went in there
i probably went too high i was like put
on your sunday's bed and i was like oh
this is over i'm a dead man
singing here this is dead i'm not gonna
continue the song
there's three and a half minutes left to
this this is gonna be hell on earth
and it's me just saying the same [ __ ] i
get like it's just
with no band it's the build is not there
it's not good
absolutely i mean i remember it ending
and my friend megan literally was like
that was really bad
oh well that was what was great about
having my brother there like i
we both acknowledged that i was like i
was taking a walk to death row when i
was going to north carolina
school of yards to sing oh that's so
beautiful and i feel like that
that brings us right to the end so we
always end uh with the same question
which is
if you could tell young gareth anything
what would you tell him oh my god
um i can't i mean
well the truth is that i think i think a
lot of it is how you have to
figure it out on your i wouldn't say
keep on going you're fine
but there was a lot of like
self-discovery that came from being
you know because my my parents were
english there was
always just a lot of figuring out i had
to do so i think what i would say
to him because he was totally lost still
is you will figure this out oh
well that's very and then i would rip
the gloves off and the sunglasses off
and i'd say dress like a regular human
when you go to [ __ ] prom you weirdo
yeah um you will figure this out but
also you look like the babadook and
[Laughter]
yeah all right gareth this is such a
wonderful episode thank you so much for
doing this pleasure thank you very much
for everybody listening at home this has
been the roast of your teenage self
podcast
you